Một bắt thằng sau các quan truyết các cao uc gọi nha đã có chuyển thăm từ Washington,
nhằm tim kiem sửng hộ mạnh mẹ hơn từ chính quyền tổng thống Mỹ Dunan Trump trong nỗ lực thúc đời sẽ phá phó bình cho cuộc sống đột đời ngà.
Đông thấy này diễn ra chỉ một ngày sau vòng đàn phá trực tiếp thứ 2, giữa phá đần nha bộ quay nha tại Istanbul, Tổn gỳ K.
Nơi 2 bên đàn đều một số thật thằng xe bộ ở về vấn đề nhân đạo.
Bá gồm mọi giọng cho đổ tu bình và hồi hương thí thế bình sĩ thiết mà.
Tránh vấn phòng tổng thống uc quay nha ông Andrew Yeh Más Sơn nhất đã có cuộc gặp với đặc phá viên Mỹ về tình hình nha của quay nha ông Kitt Kè lọc.
Cũng như đặc phá viên Mỹ về chúng đông on stick with cop.
Ông Yeh Más giảm tụi quay nha ông hộ đề xuất của Mỹ về một thật lần bắn từ thằng ba đến nay.
Và sớm sàng tụi đại của gặp cao dựa các nhà lãnh đạo ngà và Mỹ dựa kiến nè ngủ tình sấu.
Ông Yeh Más sẽ gặp ngoại trường bị mắt cô rubio để thảo lận về một số đề xuất hợp tác biến tế và tải kết.
Cũng quay nha và thích lập phủc đổi đồ thứ chung.
Tuy nhiên trong buổi cảnh ngoại ráo tích cực này,
Washington cũng đưa ra nhé cảnh bảo mạnh mẹ ấy về người gờ lâu thang của sử cho lời phòng bận cảnh Fox News.
Đặc phai viên Kitt Kè lọc cho biết, các vụ tấn công qua với của quay nha vào mại này bỏng chỉ lúc của nha một phần trong bộ bà hành nhân đang khiệm tình hình chọn nên vô cùng vử dó.
Ông nhìn mạnh mất kì hành động nào dầm bà các vương tiện măng phụ bí hành nhân.
Điều có thể tạo ra hiệu ủng tâm lý sau rau và làm trách hướng cá nỗ lực chính trị.
Cái ông Ké Lóc, của quay nà gió ra đáng trời một vản cử lớn,
thể hiện khả năng tấn công sau cho lệ thủ ngà,
tuy nhiên, ông cũng cần bảo miếp và các đồng mình cần kiểm soát tình hình,
vì việc tấn công của các cứu trên lực như vậy, có thể quả dưới hạn mà mắt sức và có thể chăm nhận.
Thông điểm này được gần ra chỉ hành ngày sau khi của quay nà tiện hành chế dịch biệt,
mà tình mạng nhét, sự giống qua vui để tấn công hàng loạt xin bay quân sự của ngà,
trên dịch zt thông thông vô lưu đi miệa zsg chức tiếp chi đau và giám đốc quân an ninh của quay nà chiến thầy,
đã pháo vi vàng làm hư hại, bụng mình một mấy bây,
tương đường bà mấy tư, phần chăm được lượng mấy bây mà tên lượng hành chình của ngà.
Dịch biệt, bên này làm giấy lên lòng ngại trong rời trức miế rằng
ngà có thể đáp trả bằng những hành động không dưới hạn,
như là khi các phương tiện thuộc buộc bộ bà hành nhân đảng bị đe gióa.